[Music]
one of the most exciting discoveries in
all of science in the past year and one
in which there will be a lot of progress
in the next five years is the discovery
of gravitational waves ripples in the
actual fabric of space-time produced
when for example two massive stars or
black holes merge into one LIGO the
laser interferometer gravitational-wave
Observatory in September of 2015
detected a signal which after months of
processing the scientists became
convinced was the signature of two black
holes merging together 1.3 billion
light-years away now this is absolutely
magnificent because it's a key
prediction of Einstein's general theory
of relativity his theory of gravity it
predicts that when two massive
especially dense objects merged together
the dimples that each of them
individually form in the shape of space
sort of form a spiral pattern that goes
outward a little bit like a water wave
when you toss a ball onto a swimming
pool and that wave carries energy and
it's extremely difficult to detect but
scientists last year detected it and
announced that result that result and I
was just blown away to black holes each
having a mass of about 30 times the mass
of the Sun merging together it's just
fantastic and a couple of more events of
that sort have been detected since then
black holes merging together as the
scientists and engineers perfect this
technique even more they will be able to
study merging neutron stars and other
kinds of Astrophysical objects and this
will allow us to study them in a way
that's simply not possible with light
with electromagnetic radiation because
gravitational waves are not a form of
electric and magnetic field
oscillating in space instead they're an
actual Ripple a little thing going out
in the shape of space and with the
passage of time showing that Einstein's
idea that massive objects really do form
a distinct dimple which then forms a
ripple of these two of these things
merge or if one of them explodes or
something like that this this theory
really is correct and it took a century
to show that that's true now the
precision of the measurement is just
mind-boggling it's by far the most
precise measurement ever made by by
anyone they had to measure the distances
of a length of well I don't want to get
into the details now but of a of their
device their device had to four
kilometer length arms and they had to
measure the length of those arms to a
precision of one one thousandth of a
proton now a proton is yay big and I
exaggerate a lot so the this four
kilometer length arm changed in length a
tiny bit as this gravitational wave was
passing through and they had to measure
this change of one one thousandth of a
proton it's as though you were measuring
the distance of the nearest star which
is 4.2 light-years or 40 million million
kilometers 40 trillion kilometers to the
width of a human hair that's the kind of
precision we're talking about imagine
measuring the distance of the nearest
star to a precision of the width of a
human hair even though the discovery of
gravitational waves was first made in
September of 2015 and announced to the
world in February of 2016 it's a very
young field there will be more such
detections and we're just beginning to
explore the universe in a way where
we're completely blind with
electromagnetic waves with light so
I anticipate huge discoveries in the
next five to ten years in the field of
gravitational wave astronomy
[Music]